because I even as I said I can't really
remember the subject matter of the
fights I only remember the emotion that
happens and the frustration but then
that becomes the fight and then that's
why you're an idiot because you're like
you're like do we just not speak the
same language I could swear it's English
[Laughter]
[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
careful boys we're currently off the
Record we got Anthony and Joe over there
we got Nick and clean and we got the
coolest Joe right here right here with
us right here
um question everybody what is the last
thing
that you fought with your partner about
the last thing yeah let me cleaner out
go ahead yes take the floor
how much time you guys got hey but that
no you ain't completely out what's the
last thing you guys fought with your
last partner about there it is
though you know technicality it's your
problem that's your technicality prop
Anthony what was the last thing you need
a thought about if you can remember
hold up are you trying to put you on
blast right now I'm trying to think for
real though I got one while he thinks
thank you thank you for saving us this
is how it goes dude I get it I've been
in that spot before where he goes to you
and you're like I don't have anything
but I got something I got a lot
I got a lot okay okay good my last your
last eight things installing
nah so um right now we've been not
fighting but we've been like bickering
about the dogs a little bit right and
like how to train them
I I've been watching a lot of YouTube
dog video training stuff to the point
where I'm like I really like it I really
like watching like dog trainers and how
they yeah they train their dogs and like
these [__] are training like
German Shepherds and like Belgian
Malinois and [__] and I'm trying to
train my two pugs you know just a funny
contrast because they're still [__]
babies yeah so I'm trying to train them
but part of it is like anytime they do a
behavior that is you don't want you have
to reprimand them in some way whether
it's like with a collar like a slip
collar or just telling them like very
certainly like no you can't do that you
know like getting in their face a little
bit so they know that like oh they can't
be doing that so like I'll argue with
Tiff about how she doesn't
address any of it and she won't
necessarily be starting with them no
don't do that yeah yeah she'll she'll do
something maybe like that or she'll just
be like ah God damn it like this little
dude you know getting mad and I'll be
like babe you have to tell them you have
to get right in their face and tell them
to stop doing that [__] or they're gonna
continue to do that and she'd be like no
but I don't want them to think that like
like I don't want them to be mad at me
and I was like no that's all this works
that's all they're not human yeah
exactly exactly but it's like we saw
reinforcements yeah well it's like you
know we we add human traits to our dogs
all the time because they're the [__]
sweetest things ever right but in
reality it's like no you we have to stop
them from doing that so this is a nice
show come home and be like oh she'll be
home all day and I'll be like how are
the dogs and I could tell she's like
clearly stressed
and then she goes they've been bullying
me all day
they're a [__] running this show but
as soon as you get home they they're all
sweet and they're all behaved my dad's
home I'm like I'm like babe you gotta
[__] tell them like you're the figure
of discipline you are the mom you gotta
[__] show them what's up you have to
tell them what you want in a household
like it's kind of funny but sometimes
like she's slowly getting it now but
it's to the point where I'm like I'm
sick and tired of having these
conversations with you and I talk
through my teeth like that you really do
I go I'm like babe you gotta [__]
you are in charge and I have to say that
you're like you have to tell them what
you want out of the situation that's not
a comical rendition you really talk to
exactly like that no I do it I do it a
little different do it yeah
lastly do it the way you really do
like I don't want to like bug you or
anything but no but but I try I try to
um be constructive yeah I don't want to
like sometimes I'll do it as a joke can
we get a role play it doesn't get it
doesn't it doesn't get across the way I
wanted to so then I have to be like no
babe seriously please like you have to
tell them what you want and what you
don't want at what point do you like
press against the side of your head like
this and grab her by her ears and I go
listen [__] listening to the dogs
yeah when you put a collar on her and go
yes I put a slip lead on her and when
she does something like
and then she beats my [__] ass
laboratory nah but that's something that
we've been like bickering about yeah
yeah yeah but it's fair yeah but it's
it's part of it yeah I just want it it
is part of it but at least you're doing
that with dogs I mean in the future
that's our that's our prep it might not
be something as cute yeah yeah it might
have 50 of my DNA
unfortunately which is a bad sign okay
well that's a healthy fight
what about you Joey you follow Hannah
lately I didn't even fight with her huh
don't say that [__] she's too reasonable
I we do uh
but he's pretty intelligent on the phone
she's yeah
dude she's quick I think the usual fight
okay I think the usual fights
that even happened or if they're called
fights or like bickering or like that
later you're just like that was so
[__] stupid
it's um we're both
we when we're like really excited or
want to explain something right like we
we might omit some vital parts of like
the story yeah and expect the other
person to understand and we're just
raising our voice like yes that's what
we said this this and this right
it's like oh [__] I forgot to say this
well like for her I'm like what are you
talking about and then she thinks I'm
saying what are you talking about like
you're an idiot but I'm actually just
pissed because I'm like I don't
understand what the [__] you're saying
yeah and then like it's like
it's because she started off with half
of the explanation because the other
half she worked it out in her head so
she fast forward through everything and
then she also thought she told me and I
didn't or maybe I wasn't listening so
it's like most of the fights are just
very different things by the way I'm the
same way this is David David So said
that you did something similar to this
to him
I don't know he said that he was talking
to you and then you went you answered
like this
and then he goes what the [__] was that
and he went oh I wrote my answer in the
air
so the funny thing is
me and Hannah were both like that she
doesn't want to admit I don't [__]
want to admit it but I admit it more
than she does and she'll probably admit
it to other people but not to me so when
you get two people like this who
have a blurred reality where we think we
told someone something or maybe when
we're excited we're not articulating
really well and we're also getting
frustrated that we can't articulate it
really well but we have a thought and
then we're going through like a rant or
something trying to explain it it's like
just being like
like a kid who's frantically trying to
say something and then the other
person's like putting pressure on it so
it gets even more frustrating because
you can't explain yourself yeah and then
so I think like a lot of the
misunderstandings come from that because
it's yeah it just stays misunderstood
yeah or she might just be telling a
story and then like I can't follow it
because it's too fast and then my mind
just goes [__] it
if you're just letting yourself
he's like I'm back there I do that
sometimes I don't know like sometimes I
have to it's just too fast like when
she's like in her mode right and then
I'm just like well wait wait go back to
that part and then I'm like ah and then
like something will distract me and I'm
like yo imagine like swinging from One
Tree to another tree they'll be sick
you're gonna be sick and then like I'm
already gone and she's like yeah yeah
yeah and then later she'll be like I
told you this thing and I'm like yeah
you probably did but I was unless
I
think it's extreme with us you never had
like a serious fight where you guys
almost like
oh like stormed out and you weren't
joking like stuff like that yeah there
was but this was I would say like last
year like it was a long time
and it's another misunderstanding thing
it was like it was a you know in the
early parts of the relationship when you
like also have insecurities mixed in
with like what you think the other
person is saying you don't understand
the other person yet well yeah so you're
confused by their reactions so you
misinterpret it it was a lot like that
so like she was dealing with some stuff
about like
moving here
and then
um having to rebuild who she was and her
identity was so tied to her work and
being really good at her job and that
was taken away right to make the choice
of being with me
and then she didn't realize how big and
difficult that road would be that I
think
um she thought that I was like looking
down on her and like insulting her
but then it was because
I had a strategy of building the shop
yeah my goal was first I was going to
learn the the strategy from the
franchise then I'm gonna create my own
system of teaching and I wanted to teach
someone to see if it worked or not and
she was going to be my first person that
I teach the system to so the whole time
she was like why aren't you telling me
why aren't you involving me and I'm all
like because I want you unbiased oh
that's that makes sense right but then I
wasn't doing a good job explaining my
method of I'm gonna bring you in but let
me bring you in after I learn this and
then you learn so then it was kind of
like a huge Club because then you get to
practice teaching right because it's
like and then I brought my nephew in and
then she goes you're gonna bring his
young ass in before me like you don't
respect and then I was just like no I
know there's a family business we're all
in this together you know but then like
nepotism
how dare you but then also like as I was
working at out the system I wasn't doing
a good job relaying that but that's been
my idea now I can explain it better yeah
but then yeah so then it was just like
all of that cluster [__] and then
um I think like after I was able to
explain she goes oh duh why don't you
just say that in the first place and I'm
like because I can't explain [__] girl
you know like yeah good way of putting
it but I think that was that would
probably be the most of the issue and
then now she knows who I am and like how
I operate and your intentions yeah yeah
that you're not listening yeah one of
the this is one of the funniest biggest
fights that we had right
um so when we're doing long distance I
was like I want some [__] nude videos
give me some [__] to jack off to yeah
and then she was like hell yeah right
that's all you want when you're freaking
away they're like easy Minnesota one
month turn to two months and I got paid
I was like dude what the [__] like yeah
spread those [__] lips like what
happened that's all you got right you
give her reference videos but I was more
confused because I was like you're
talking to me every day and then we do
get sexual but like what like what is
because she did send me nudes before it
wasn't the first time so I was like what
what's the hold up right she got you
already I need a nut right
you can perform him no more
and then I got mad not because of like I
wasn't getting the nude but I got mad
because she wasn't explaining and
communicating so I felt like I'm getting
[__] confused here right right and
then she said oh okay I'm embarrassed
because I gained weight I feel
uncomfortable I don't feel hot and I'm
all like
oh
now I understand interesting she doesn't
feel hot even when you're saying spread
those [__] lips
[Laughter]
it's so clear yeah
yeah it's very remarkable yeah it's
clear Direction yeah she's not thinking
about swinging from tree to tree when
he's talking about that you know so how
did you navigate
well then what did you
do because that's a hard I
was like
so we're we're talking intimately yeah
am I not turning you on like what's
going on and she goes no she goes I'm
dealing with some [__] on my own it's my
own like she's like I don't feel hot and
then like I think she got sick or
something so she wasn't in the mood to
be presentable so then the longer she
put it off oh and she was working like
14 hour like gigs right right so then I
think everything was just she wasn't
also explaining her thought process and
what we realized is like
we don't want to jump to conclusions and
be like and assume the worst in people
but the longer you don't explain
something it forces us to get confused
and then the confusion is what turns
into irritation yeah because it's like
well why like this is out of character
for you right and I think
that's where we realize most of our uh
fights would come from is like when one
person's just not
updating the other person so then it
just comes into like what's going on and
then the other person can't explain it
yeah but then now I think when we worked
all of that [__] out so she eventually
sent you some materials yeah
it's great news
that's great news this is good that was
a prize
you said her back material yeah yeah
what do you send her what do you think
the most I've ever seen him light up
today
this is his wheelhouse baby look at him
what do you send back we hit his like
point of Interest
yeah what do you set Meg I sent dick
pictures do you do anything cool dude oh
you know what I found out what yeah a
good a good tripod is
yeah you're you are a coffee cup guy
yeah you could do that he always carries
a coffee cup with them you put a coffee
cup and then you put the phone there and
then you're free to are you sick
are you doing a profile
one leg up on there yeah
[Laughter]
are you like taking your hair and
covering your like face being exotic gel
exotic I didn't have my hair was
shoulder length and are you smiling are
you like smoldering what's the face that
goes with that are you standing live are
you going and when you have your hair
off no I mean you turn off hair to the
front or the back
or so it's both it's mainly torso okay
okay you know that one girl that that
took a bunch of dick pics
like this is how guys take big dick pics
and it's a meme that goes all around oh
it's like that yeah so it's actually
very close to the real thing it's very
basically she's spot on yeah yeah nice
to know if if Steve was here he would
have said that I would have had one bent
over too I was assuming you were just
sitting in [__] pics right off top
yeah that is kind of funny to do yeah
like if it's a joke it's like coming
from the back front so you just see the
[__] balls you see the hanging song
but you get the whole I'm like that's a
joke photo do you add music or you just
like leave the raw audio
you know what I should have done that
started movie
I should have thought of it more I think
production yeah I was not I was not hey
you're an indie Studio yeah yeah I think
most of my flights with smack are also
very stupid like and thankfully so like
why didn't you give me a dick to be
honest the thing we fight about the most
is so goddamn typical yeah but the the
our most frequent fight is what do you
want to eat
really nothing and then you go I just
found out how hard it is to always
figure out something my little sister
just moved in with me I'm taking care of
her now and trying to figure out
something new to eat every single day
because she's so picky that's tough yeah
bro that's tough It's hard what does she
like to eat it's weird she's not picky
she just doesn't like to eat the same
things so like if we eat one thing she
doesn't like to have leftovers normally
and then I think that's just a girl
thing dude I think so too honestly
because like I'm so I'm so
and ground beef every day until I die
yeah I feel like I yeah I'm I'm pretty
freaking simple but yeah did you have to
yeah did you know Postmates it has like
a repeat order button yeah yeah I could
do that all day all day and then so like
every time I ask her like oh what do you
want to eat then it's like a
what do you want to eat yeah and then it
of course is that thing of like oh we
could just go here I'll eat that no not
that like it's very typical did she say
when you ask her what do you want to eat
does she go I want something fresh
okay that's your girl yeah has your girl
ever said that you go I want something
fresh I'm like okay what's that
she goes well that's that's the hard
part too is that it's hard to get hit
like at least that's a hint and you can
narrow it down yeah but it's hard for me
to narrow down with her I usually have
to just go you want something Asian yeah
Asian holy [__] you know what it is
maybe she'll say yeah you know what it
is is you should
but you know what's sad I do that so
much that like you're tired of it no no
no I I'll do it to the point where like
five decisions later so go if I never
liked that oh yeah that's tough why did
you say anything that's tough
that's what we're fighting about
but they probably don't want they don't
want to be the cliche right they don't
want to she doesn't want to be the the
but then like we I do tell her like in
the moment I'm like this is super like
funny and cliche that we're excited
about this same like stereotypical [__]
but I'm wondering what do the girlies
eat and decide when the guys aren't
around have you seen the meme that's
been going around the [__] girl
dinner thing they just chop up
vegetables they just eat the most random
[__] no we just do this all day dog if I
was at home my tip would just eat chips
and then like girl dinner and then like
sometimes I'll come home and she'll be
like she'll be waiting for me to come
home and then she'll be like I'm hungry
and she's kind of clearly in a bad mood
I'm like you need nothing bro yeah yeah
sometimes I'll literally come home and
she'll be like I haven't eaten all day
I'm like what
and she's like I've been waiting for you
to come home so we can go eat I was like
what's the point of me filling up the
fridge
if you're not gonna have
I'm about to be talking through his
teeth
I'm like what's the point of me filling
up the fridge with Plum cots and
cherries if you're not gonna have a
couple bites dude you know when you're
hungry that's pretty funny actually
that's fine I just threw out a whole
thing I just threw out a whole bag of
cherries because my sister wanted them
oh she only ate like two or three bro
and tell the audience how expensive tell
the JK audience how expensive food is
very expensive cherries are like bro you
buy one bag it's like 14 bucks damn you
get the Rainer cherries forget about it
dude you [__] kidding me
you know so much about food man rain or
cherries they're so good dude are they
extra sweet
if they're in season if there's the last
thing that we thought about that wasn't
that was so much Dumber we were at Best
Buy trying to buy like a hard drive or
some [__] something stupid I don't
even remember what the device was now oh
it was like a DVD like a we needed to
play a DVD so I could rip it so we're
getting a player like an LG one damn and
it had like a USB like C or USB two
whatever we were in there fighting about
like whether or not we had the adapter
and I was like it doesn't matter I have
every USB and she's like yeah but that's
USBC I'm like I don't care def I got it
I'm a [__] nerd so she didn't think
you had it no well I didn't we were
saying a different thing it wasn't even
like if you were listening to us you
could probably just stop and go she's
not talking about that you're not
talking about this it's like we were
just saying different [__] I feel like
that's 50 of male to female arguments
right it's like we think I think she's
saying one thing and I'm completely
misconstructed is you need an adapter
for the argument
power a converter yeah of course my
dumbass escalated the fight because
eventually I stopped and went
the [__] is up with our communication
what the [__] is this
I feel like like am I just crazy I feel
like that's how it always is right it's
like the emotions of something really
dumb because I even as I said I can't
really remember the subject matter of
the fights I only remember the emotion
that happens and the frustration but
that's like all but then that becomes
the fight and then that's why you're an
idiot because you're like why did you
take it up a notch and I'm starting to
go like dude we just not [__] speak
the same language I could swear it's
English
[Laughter]
that always goes real well does an
Australian accent really change the
meanings of USB cords like what the [__]
is this like we were like hella like bad
and then come come and come to uh find
out we get home like this [__] stupid
ass charger I look in my drawer I don't
have that
because like it's like she wanted to
watch this uh TV series from her
childhood that's why she had this old
DVD so instead of being like hey I don't
got the chord uh we gotta go get one
[__] I [__] pirated it and I'm
like hey I did it check it out
oh [__] and I was like and then I put it
on the living room TV before she can say
anything and I played it and it was
already on she goes you did it I'm like
yeah
hahaha
hey it doesn't matter how as long
that's so man style yeah like anything
to not be wrong just figure it out bro
you just figure it out yeah you need to
not be wrong
now you have a [__] DVD player for no
reason for no end to make matters worse
we already [__] had one
yeah I was looking for the cord I found
it I saw it I'm like oh [__] that
[__] throw this away
same exact LG DVD player [__] dumb
dude
[Music]
foreign